i'm very excited about our next guest uh
james mcavoy
the talented actor is making his new
york stage debut in cyrano de bergerac
winner of the lawrence olivier
award in london for best revival mcavoy
plays cyrano a soldier and a poet played
with a large nose who becomes wrapped up
in a love triangle the actors perform
this modern adaptation of the classic
play in the style of spoken word poetry
and at times they even rap the
production comes to the brooklyn academy
of music from london's west end where
one reviewer called mcavoy's performance
a tour de force
and james mcavoy
you buy into that welcome james mcavoy
thank you for having me i dressed up
just for you james mcavoy amazing i
can't believe you got in at 2 am you are
a modern-day hero no and i was saying
where's your sparkly tuxedo he said no
this is the best i could do we're really
thrilled that you're here thank you
having me probably well
you say tour de force tour de force man
yeah you know they call it as they see
it you know what i'm saying
well you're stepping back into this role
you played it once before and you're
stepping back into it what's it like
it's amazing it's an incredible
role i think it always is in any version
an incredible role for a performer but
martin kremp's modern adaptation it
really examines a hell of a lot of what
it is to be objectified in the modern
age as well
and i think weirdly when we did it two
years ago it went down a storm but i
think we've all spent two years
experiencing
isolation and loneliness yes and i don't
know maybe that's why having now doing
it two years later audiences are finding
it all the more funny and all the more
sadder uh all the more sadder all the
more sad
and and maybe it's because of that two
years of living that experience that the
three main characters in this show
really experienced not just sereno but
roxanne and christian they're all
intensely lonely and isolated and we i
think we so crave human connection it's
just nice to be out and see really good
work on the stage i was surprised james
at how physical this role is yeah well
you in particular yeah he's a soldier
look i like throwing myself around stage
so it's something yeah i lend myself to
if i can the role really lets me he's a
soldier he's a warrior poet and the poet
part always gets um
lent into and we do of course lean into
that massively in this production but
he's also the warrior part as well and
so the physicality was really important
to uh delve into i i don't know what a
big nose is how you would define that
exactly but i guess you'd call it when
you see it i wouldn't say yours is and
do not wear a prosthetic others who have
revived this character have yes take me
through the thinking i would think it
was the director's thinking jamie lloyd
amazing director's the only theater
director i've worked with for like 15
years he's amazing he said you want to
do sereno i said yes he says i don't
want to do it with a nose i said isn't
it about i'll tell you about a guy with
a nose
i said no it's a player but a guy who's
objectified and and his thinking i think
is that the minute you've got some big
fake thing you saw of
undermine the truth of everything
uh whereas when you've got this guy
walking on stage going i hate myself
because of the way i look and he's not
wearing some big fake thing and you're
going but you don't even look so bad
yeah profundity and the truth of that
that sadness and that pain becomes all
the more real but also the most
i don't know the guy with the
punctuation mark right beside him the
guy who's underlined isn't on stage so
then you get to see every single
character and you get to go god they've
all got a nose yeah they've all got
something that's holding them back is
something they hate about themselves
everybody has issues everybody's got
something you know and by the way the
other thing i think right no matter how
big the noses are that i've seen in
productions of sir no i'm always like
someone out there would find that
attractive some well that's the point
right we'll get that kink on with that
big old probiscus
guaranteed like you will find that
person just hanged off you're gonna find
that person well i love the fact that
you're wearing like the kind of clothes
that you wear in everyday life yeah um
and the point that director made which
is that anything can be objectified we
objectify
ourselves all the time
the nose probably when that play was
written was one way to do it but now we
can do it in a different way exactly i
think um
i think look i'm not somebody who thinks
that social media is the the the evil
that has you know tarnished the world on
every corner but
i do think that it used to be you had to
be
well-known you had to be on magazine
covers you had to be in movies or making
music or something like that in order to
be objectified by the grand masses but
each of us now if you've got an
instagram profile or you've got some
twitter thing going on we all know what
it's like now to be dissected criticized
made fun of whatever it is like
everybody understands this now on a
deeper level than i think by people who
don't know you don't what do you think
about you and you take that in yeah and
feel completely free and anonymous to
just rip you to shreds you know can we
talk about the last line of the play
because i love the last line as i'm
saying can you just say the last line uh
what is the last the last language
uh the hero always has to have the final
the final and i'm so i'm sitting in i'm
screaming say the word say the word say
the word and you don't well it's an
unfinished sentence yes i mean i am
really surprised that uh in the 160 odd
times that we've done this show as the
lights go down we haven't had something
nobody's going out word
[Laughter]
you know what the previous previous
versions of this play uh
have sereno dying going out on a high
he's a hero walking over the hill as he
heads off to heaven you know and i think
that what this production it doesn't
allow him that and it's partly i think
because this production honors the fact
or recognizes the fact that christiane
and
cyrano really mistreat roxanne yes they
love her yes they feel terrible about
the fact that he's got a big nose and
yeah christian can't he's not got the
intelligence and that's poor them but
they manipulate her and they mistreat
her to the point of abuse and i think
this production honors that so it
doesn't quite let him have his hero send
off on purpose you know that's because
martin creme's just an amazing writer
it's not often you get to see a tour de
force in person awesome wonderful
congratulations
bravo worth the price of admission thank
you sir